[Laughter]
[Music]
hello matthew
hello joe what's going on man you got a
book out
got a book out got green lights trying
to catch him trying to create him
what makes a guy who is successful as
you as an actor what makes you want to
expose
more of yourself because that's kind of
what you're doing by writing a memoir
right you're exposing your thought
process
your your your life your lessons
another another way of communicating uh
you know what i do
my day job as an actor um
it's got four filters from the raw
expression
there's what i've there's my raw
expression there is what's being
recorded there's what's being
edited and there's what's being put on
the screen
um i wanted to do something where i got
rid of the filters
writing a book there is one filter
because it's the written word
um what you do what we're doing now when
you do stand up
that's no filters you know that's the
direct it's live
the the big show is always recording uh
sort of ultimate goal but i wanted to uh
i wanted to put it down and say hey i
want to
i'm part of these movies they're usually
written by somebody else directed by
somebody else
edited by someone else finance but
someone was like no i want to go direct
my own movie i want to produce my own
movie while i do that i want to put the
words on a page and i'd been writing for
36 years so i had
a lot of content to go through and see
if it was something worthy of sharing
yeah so you've been keeping a journal
for 36 years
yeah what made you start doing that i
think
probably in the beginning the usual
reason someone writes in a journal you
know
well my heart's broken gretchen donnelly
broke up with me
on my face why do i only have peach fuzz
over my pecker and everyone else
and then in my early 20s um i remember
i was i was kind of rolling i was in
college i had a job i had money in my
pocket i had a nice girlfriend
making my grades my relationships were
good
and i remember going oh you hadn't been
writing in your journal near as much
notice you don't do that so much johnny
when things are going well and i said
i think you better start writing down
things when things are going well
i mean my go my idea was that hey you're
going to get in a rut again
you'll lose your frequency again in life
you might want this to go back and look
at to help you recalibrate and that
proved to be true
um you know so many times we dissect
failure and
and and hardships my life but we don't
dissect success
and going back in those journals i found
that there were times when i
got in a rut later and i was able to go
back to those journals and go what were
your habits when you were rolling man
who were you hanging out with where were
you going what were you eating what were
you drinking how much
how much sleep were you getting how are
you looking at life and
they'd helped me recalibrate in the
times when i was off frequency and get
back on the rails again and find my
frequency again
what were the things that when things
were going great what
what was what were the common factors
common factors were one
check in with yourself before checking
in with the world when you wake up in
the morning
um really to sit there and take a little
time um
read a little something that's between
me and me write a little something
that's between me and me before picking
up the damn phone and saying hey what
emails came in
or hopping out in the kitchen and going
and everyone else is already up going
hey hey what's up
take take take take 10 minutes to check
in
with me before checking in with the
world um
what were the other things sense of
humor sense of humor
um i found that i was laughing more um
my happiest time in my life when i got
my wink back
man when i got my wink if i lose my wink
it's like oh i'm taking things too
seriously
um so i had
i had more of a sense of humor um didn't
they take things as personal
in in many ways um and
wasn't asking permission as much
when i was rolling asking permission
like what do you mean by that
well just asking permission about going
you know having the confidence to
believe in something i want to do and
just doing it
and saying hey if you ask permission
you're already creating one of those
filters
away from the raw expression just do it
it's live don't
you can what you're saying what it
sounds like is like you almost like
self-medicated with a type of medication
or a type of meditation that you
invented yourself
you almost like figured out a meditation
because that's what people who meditate
that's what they say to do take an you
know x amount of time
10 20 whatever it is minutes out of the
day
focus on your breathing clean the mind
out of anxiety and stress
and if you do that on a regular basis
you'll have a happier life
and you seem to have figured that out on
your own or did you read books about
doing this i think i figured it out on
my own i mean the other thing that i
didn't tell you was to book in the day
before i say my prayers at night to go
through the day
which i don't know about you but it can
be hard to remember what you had for
breakfast
after dinner when you're going to bed it
can be hard to remember what those first
things we did in the day so
i'll go back through my day when i'm
happiest i go back to my day
and i like to write a mental note of
what is tomorrow
what are my plans for tomorrow um that's
a big stress reliever
for for me um i i think i learned it on
my own
i've always been a list keeper i love
making a long list of things to do
during the day and i add
everything i add the simple things that
you know you're going to do anyway
in in the list you know like kiss your
wife
you know what i mean drop a deuce
whatever
it is i i write things that i'm going to
do just so it's more to mark off the
list
you write you write down you have to
take a [ __ ]
like really just remember you know enjoy
enjoy that or read something
read something funny or or have a listen
to that favorite tune of yours
something that i know because the longer
the list the more things i can mark off
that day the more i feel like i
accomplished and the more it makes it
kind of easy to do the hard stuff you
know
i yeah i do that with some things that i
have to do like exercise
and writing i do that with some things
but it seems like you're
very meticulous with this yeah i go
through hot streaks and cold streaks on
it
you know i do it more times than others
but i've found that those are the common
denominators some of the things i do
when i
am the most happy i'm not a big
meditator
but my exercise i call breaking a sweat
once a day
exercising i find for me that is
necessary because it puts a demarcation
between all of
my responsibilities and i could
sometimes look up
you know how it is if sometimes you go
through the day or days and you're so
busy
and i'm i'm good on autopilot getting
stuff done but
everything you have to do stress comes
when those responsibilities feel like
they're stacked vertically
on our shoulders and there's a
proverbial weight
on our shoulders when i go break a sweat
all of a sudden all those things that
were stacked vertically on my shoulders
my responsibilities
lay down and they're laterally out in
front of me
so there's no more weight on my shoulder
and i find that i get those things done
better and with more enjoyment if i just
go oh there they are in front of you
just handle one then hop to the next one
handle that and hop to the next one and
handle that
i handle much more better but i need
those i see demarcations between
my responsibilities if i go break a
sweat
yeah i couldn't agree more with that i
think there's there's a biological need
for that when human beings are under
pressure
because i think the way our bodies are
set up pressure
historically genetically meant your life
was in danger
and you had to exert energy and your
body stored up this energy you you had
adrenaline rushes you had anxiety you
had all these different
physical needs that you had to take care
of and if you don't exert
energy those physical needs are not met
your body's confused it stores up a lot
of this and you just
you get anxious you yell at red lights
and people just
freak out generally your tolerance for
[ __ ] is way lower
but if you can just get that physical
need taken care of you're way
better at handling life way better
way better yeah i couldn't tell people
that enough
i'm a broken record with it i say it too
much and i i love
hearing people like yourself successful
people
that have thought about a lot of the
various aspects of
what's good and bad about their life
expressed that because i think
everyone needs to hear it it's just we
need to hear it from enough people so
that it just get becomes ingrained in
everyone's head
every day brush your teeth every day
break a sweat just just go do it i mean
it's good for so many things yeah
you know people talk about oh you know
no stress i'm like well [ __ ] yeah
the stress is probably fine it means you
give a damn you know what i mean
you're gonna have stress you're supposed
to have stress but i know i handle
things better
and more thoroughly and more like myself
like i want to
the outcome is always better and i enjoy
doing it more if
i do go break that sweat and get those
endorphins going
and that presses reset for me and it
shows me a little it separates all the
events like i said laterally and they
don't feel like they're stacked up on
top of me
yeah also sleep sleep for me how much do
you get a night
nine and a half i love it
that's great i wish i could do that god
damn
when i get a nine and a half out an hour
night oh my god i feel so good the next
day
i feel amazing i feel like a newer
person
well my i'm lucky i have a wife that
says
no no you get your nine and a half i'll
get my seven
because i'd rather handle the stuff i
handle that you don't while you're
sleeping than be around you when you
hadn't had enough sleep
ah well you set it up right
yeah i i can't stress that enough too
sleep is is everything
sleep exercise health keep the body
functioning correctly
all those things they they they're not
just
it's it's not a vanity thing and it's
not a laziness
thing it's literally like it improves
the quality of the way the mind
functions
and you get better things done your the
quality of your work will be better
definitely think more clearly you don't
waste your time chasing down [ __ ]
you don't you know you do the right kind
of work
you know we all know that i i love hard
work but i've got many times in my life
where i'm doing the wrong kind of work
i love the kind of work where i've
accomplished what i needed to do during
the day
and i lay my head on the pillow and i'm
exhausted because i got
done what i needed to get done as best i
could i do not like the exhaustion at
the end of the day where i'm like
man i feel like i was just going to
revolutions man i don't know if today
had any ascension to it i didn't build
anything and today was a
i don't know if i maybe i went backwards
you know i don't like that kind of
exhaustion
um and that's the kind of exhaustion
that actually i don't go to sleep well i
actually keeps me up
the only thing i get good out of those
shitty days is a desire to never have
those shitty days
again i think the the good the good
aspects of negative feelings is
recognizing how good positive feelings
are how good
the feelings of accomplishment are by
failing and
that's why we're talking about you know
like no stress
just live in peace that's a crock of
[ __ ] that's like never feel bad
well then you're never going to
appreciate feeling good like
yeah i need hills and valleys i'm with
you
uh 100 on that i mean i write in my book
you know and i get asked a lot do you
believe in fear
and i'm like well hell yeah i believe in
the future who the [ __ ] doesn't believe
in fear
well you know you see there's like no
fear oh those people are so silly
like no no no no i do and they're like
do you do fear i said i have fear every
single day it's the overcoming of the
fear
or i know being raised you know we were
a physical disciplined family
we got we got the belt we didn't get
grounded my parents motto was
we're not going to ground you because
that takes away your time and your time
is your most valuable thing no we never
got
injured we just get hurt at the time you
cried and it was over with but there
were things that i did not do growing up
and still do not do
for fear of the consequences that
your works for me gone i retired things
i did not do growing up going like no
that'd be a lot of fun but
not so much not more fun than how much
it's gonna suck if i get caught
[Laughter]
physical consequences are it's a very
controversial subject
because a lot of people think i don't
hit my kids
but a lot of people that i know who are
my age were hit
when they were young and they look back
on it and they say you know what
i learned from that and my parents
didn't they didn't
beat me they physically punished me for
something that i did wrong
and they they didn't do it to be
sadistic they did it because they cared
about me and that's how they were raised
it's a very controversial subject
because people get up in arms with the
idea of hitting
children you know so yeah you bringing
it up that that it was beneficial to you
is going to have a lot of people's
hackles raised sure and i get asked all
the time
and i've shared it openly how i was
raised and what kind of corporal
punishment we got
i don't choose to you know discipline my
children the same way my parents did
but i've said this before i wouldn't
trade one
single of those ass weapons i got for
the values that were instilled in me
from getting them and i'm very clear and
was at the time
that i earned every one i got
i earned everyone and
we were family you know my parents were
like we get it over with
and over take it and it's over and we
don't hold grudges no one's going to
speak of it again
and if you got in trouble that was the
night dad would take us across town to
our favorite burger joint and let us
stay as late as we wanted
it was and it was over um you got more
trouble if you brought something back
up you know to somebody in the family
yeah but what about when you do that no
no they already got in trouble for that
you don't bring it back up you could not
go to sleep in our family holding a
grudge
my parents would stay up all night and
let you miss school to sit there and
keep hashing out until we could hug it
out
cry it out and say i love you and move
on sounds like you had
a wise family i mean it's it's a
controversial thing to say
if they hit you and a lot of people
would say
there's other ways to do it but the way
they
made you hug it out and stay up all
night and communicate it sounds very
wise
i think it was you know i don't uh you
know like i said
i don't choose to discipline my kids the
way my parents discipline me
but i damn sure don't judge them or say
what they did was wrong
came from a different era as well right
yeah
yeah that's a thing that is very
difficult for people to
come to grips with is that you know
human beings that were raised 30 40 50
60 years ago they
it was a different world it just was
different
and we know more now and like you're
saying you do not choose to discipline
your children that way
but it was so common back then
it was yeah i mean it was you know
my parents were probably thought they
were taking it easy on their boys
more than their parents treated them yes
they probably had it much more harsh
yeah um
you know and it's a it's a like i said i
there are things i did not do that i
should not have done
for fear hitting my backside
so you know there's value in that in
that fear and consequences
and consequences go both ways you know
there's goblins in the bathroom there's
a consequence for everything we do but
there were
definitely things i didn't do that i
should not have done uh for the fear of
the consequences
that were useful to me is this
the writing of this book is some of it
almost like like letters
to your younger self like a lesson
to people who are like you coming up
because one of the things that's so
beneficial
uh to young people with reading
autobiographies and memoirs of
successful people lived
extraordinary lives is you get to see
all the thought process you get to see
the the warts
the failures the the whole thing the
fears the anxiety you get to see it all
so you go
oh that matthew mcconaughey guy he's a
normal dude
he's not just the guy from dallas buyers
club and all these movies
he's a normal human being and maybe
i can one day achieve heights
like him as well or
maybe i i read this book and i'm someone
who feels like
you know as we often do when we're going
through a crisis that we're the only
ones
and it's only happened to me i'm the
center of the universe no one else will
understand and you can read and go
well here's a guy who's successful who
shoot i even maybe thought he just kind
of rolls out of bed and makes everything
look easy which you find out
i i try to work to get to that point but
maybe you look and you hear and you go
oh he went through some similar things i
share some stories in here that are very
subjective to me
but the more subjective and personal i
got the more i found that oh these are
more relatable to the more amount of
people
out there so you may read a story and go
i have that story a similar story in my
life
well here's how mcconaughey handled it
or wished he would have handled it or
here's some help he got along the way
here's somewhere where he's
he took a walk about with himself and
found out some things about himself
maybe that's something i could do for
myself so there are some tools in the
book for someone to see themselves in
and help navigate our way out of crisis
red and yellow lights but also how to
navigate things when we are catching
green lights because
i have a chapter here called the art of
running downhill
um you know i i self-sab i've
self-sabotaged myself when things were
going too well before
um until i learned that that really
wasn't my right
to to put a roof over my expectations
for myself and who the hell did i think
i was
well that's more common than not isn't
it there's the people get
what they call uh was imposter syndrome
you know it's you don't feel like you
deserve all the good things that are
happening to you
and it just seems odd you see it happen
to other people it almost makes sense
you see other people being very
successful
it you're detached but when it's
happening to you it's almost like this
this is uncomfortable because this is
not normal
and so i'm gonna [ __ ] this up so that i
i feel
like i used to feel before which at
least even if it was failure
it's comfortable i'm accustomed to it i
need some resistance
yes you know and look and i think
there's very healthy
ways to create resistance in our lives
when we are on so-called easy street
yeah that maybe not challenging
ourselves in the right way you know that
we need to create resistance to overcome
it
to feel most alive but there's also
foolish times to create resistance and
the fact of that
is things are going so well you think
that's how it's going to be for the rest
of your life no trust me the uphill's
coming the drama the real drama is
coming don't create any false
drama in front of you right now because
you're kind of patronizing yourself
the real drama is going to come someone
is going to get sick you are going to
get hurt
something will happen in your life the
world will do unto you or you'll do it
unto yourself
so don't trip yourself running downhill
and face plant
and break your freaking nose just
because you needed some resistance
running downhill
yeah because it must be that uphill is
coming you know what i mean but
to go back to the first part of that i'm
i'm a big fan of creating
resistance to keep myself in check and
to make sure
that i'm feeling most alive to overcome
the right things in my life
yeah me as well i i find physical
resistance is the best thing to calm my
mind
and and to provide physical challenges
that allow me to
it allows me to deal with uh success
easier because there's [ __ ] that i
have to deal with but the [ __ ] is
physical
and it's sometimes is challenging
mentally to do
you know like very physically exerting
exercises or
particularly jiu jitsu or martial arts
because it just
it breaks you down and so then the the
other stuff
that's sort of it seems like it should
be
complicated but it's not you don't know
why you don't sweat it as much
wait it sobers you up yes in a very
literal way in in the same way
it's a daily routine to sober yourself
up to to throw off the mendacious
[ __ ] in your life that you were so
concerned about
and get down to what really needs to
happen mountains become mole hills
you know it it it's you know big moments
in our life sober us up too i know my
father moving on and passing on from
this life
sobered me up in a way that i then
stepped up and said oh
you don't have your dad to rely on
anymore to catch you when you fall
all these things he's been teaching you
that you've been kind of making b
b minuses in life now you better start
making a's at him because
he's not there so you better take some
ownership and i remember when he moved
on
i carved this in a tree be less
impressed more involved
and what it was as soon as he passed
away i noticed that all the things that
i was revering in life
mortally like the fame people that
success
money they lowered down to eye level
things that i was looking up at and all
the things that i was patronizing and
condescending and going i was sloughing
off that's not worthy of me
they rose up to eye level and i remember
saying boy the world is flat i'm looking
it in the eye
i see further i see wider i see clearer
um i've got to take ownership of myself
and i stood with my heart higher i stood
my head higher and i walked forward and
started doing things and that way that i
was saying er without asking so much
permission all the time and got a lot
more done and became a lot more
myself and found more satisfaction yeah
sometimes people do need
some wake-up call to let you know that
this is a temporary existence
and make the best out of it and enjoy
and sometimes it doesn't happen unless
something tragic happens like they are
in a terrible way but also a beautiful
way there's a lot of power and tragedy
because you you get something on the
other end of it
and you get clarity we will get
some clarity out of this tragic and
awkward time of covid
yes there are lessons we're learning
that we don't even know what they are
right now
that when we get out of it will
inherently be part of our being that
will go forward i sure as hell hope so
but you know us humans we're quick to
snap right back to how we were before
yeah my concern is that it's t it's
happening so fast
but it's going to take a long time to
sort of even out
and for us to reach equilibrium
that's what i'm worried about with this
wait that what's happening
deterioration that you know the
financial deterioration the fear the
changes with the masks and the social
distancing and
everything is happening so fast i'm
worried it's just going to take a long
time before people feel comfortable
again
oh yeah i mean look i think for for
for millions of people yeah
this the new normal i think i don't
think we're ever
really going back to how it was i mean
this is a year that
agree or disagree with how we've gone
about it and how things have been
politicized here and there this is a
year that have
shaken our floor i don't believe this is
ever this
year is going to be on page 14 of the
news for quite some time
i think we got a lot of rebuilding to do
in the long term it may be a
20-year build yeah i know i agree
it's uh it's just strange it just feels
strange you go outside the world just
feels
different than it felt a year ago and
that's
that phrase the new normal that people
like to bring up and this is uh this is
where we find ourselves but i
along with you i'm i'm almost always
optimistic
and uh i have a lot of faith in human
beings and i think that
we can get through this and and have a
very valuable lesson
about when things do happen that are
positive and good
maybe we won't take it for granted as
much as we did before because we never
thought that something like this was
ever gonna come along where
the whole world was gonna shut down for
seven eight nine ten who knows how many
months
yeah forced winter yeah we had one first
upon us in something that we don't
take enough time to force upon ourselves
and choose upon ourselves to do
you know you talked about optimism which
i'd love to open that up with you and
faith in mankind
and i was asked the other day about how
do i trust
and this is a time in the world where
there's great distrust and people don't
believe you don't just trust you don't
you don't trust others you end up not
trusting yourself
et cetera that's a rest of process it
goes back and forth and then everyone's
walking in circles
but my answer and i never thought about
it until this guy asked me i was like
well
like i'm talking to you right now joe i
give you you have 100
of my trust until you don't
i'm not coming in hedging my bet with
you or anyone that i meet for the first
time i'm not coming in like well
you're gonna have to really earn your
trust with me i'm looking out for you
no you have a hundred percent you may
ask me some questions right now that i'm
like going i think he's getting
something else that's not really in my
best interest and maybe then you start
losing some of my trust but as of right
now we meet you have a hundred percent
until it starts to decrease and that's
all that's up to you i try to go
towards everybody like that first
so how is that and let's talk about
optimism because
there's foolish optimism there's like
and i don't think what you and i are
saying is hey
class half full always see it half full
no
let's recognize that it's half empty
that's the inevitable part it's half
empty or tap full
now what's the constructive way forward
what can you do something with the
the half the glass got nothing in it or
a half it's got something in it
well i think what i can do is is with
the half it's got something in it make
something
it irrigates and create more water so i
can fill it up i mean it's
choosing where can we be constructive
and in the af
choose the affirmative and that's not a
foolish optimism because
a lot of times i think certain optimisms
hallmark card optimisms can
almost deny that there was the other
half of glass that was
empty or denied it's a problem and i'm
not into
i'm not not really a purchaser of
denying where there's a problem
you've got you've got what i call
whiskey philosopher wisdom
like if you and i were having a couple
of drinks at the bar
i have a feeling you would say some cool
[ __ ]
that i would remember and i would take
home and i'd go hmm i'd be like lying in
bed going damn
i'm gonna remember that that makes a lot
of sense
where'd you get that from ah i think i
mean i grew up in
founded storytellers i love drinks i
love
bumper stickers i love slogans i love to
deconstruct a big conversation down to
what's a one-liner what's the title of
that song we just sang
what's the title of this you know this
hour or whatever you and i
talk um what's the title of a
relationship i have what's the
and you get enough of those things oh
what's the album title um
i i think of things lyrically and i
think that may be where it comes from as
i think in a musical in a musical way is
this
something you've acquired is this
something you always had or you just
sort of
slowly developed it i think i'm guessing
it was slowly developed i mean again i
come from a from a
family of storytellers where we sat
around the table and told stories and if
you didn't tell your story good
somebody else the table took it over and
you speak up you better be telling a
good story and not dragging on or losing
your train of thought because somebody
else will step in and
roll over you right so when you wanted
to get a word in
you better be a good storyteller well is
that how you got into acting
like this the ability to entertain
because the storyteller is essentially
an entertainer
sure well i went to film school first
because
when i look back at the diaries i really
couldn't admit that i wanted to be in
front of the camera as an actor
but that's what i really wanted to do um
but i went to film school because i felt
like
being a storyteller behind the camera
was something that
my dad one could digest as a possible
route forward for his son and it was all
that i could digest at the time
um so when i made the leap to film
school i immediately
would direct actors by performing myself
in front of the camera
so i really liked the the the first
person subjective performance
and then i got that that job in that
summer of 92 on days confused
where i ended up three lines turned into
three weeks work i'm getting paid 320
bucks a day
people tell me i'm good at it i keep
getting invited back to set i'm like
is this [ __ ] legal um yes
and so i went back graduated picked up
and
packed up my u-haul and drove west young
man you know two weeks out of
out of graduating college and
you know i didn't have that story
of roughing it when i first got out
there first two auditions i went on i
got the job
that's pretty [ __ ] amazing yeah did
you when when you say that
you you didn't want to admit that you
wanted to be
in front of the camera like what do you
think was holding you back
i think it was the id look i was raised
in a blue collar family where you get a
job you work your way up the ladder
company ladder
to be in the arts to be in front of a
camera the actors sounded so
vain sounded so avant-garde sounded so
european
sounded so so so nothing stable about it
and so to bring that up to my dad
even bring it up like i said i could it
was not even in the vernacular of my
dreams i did not even dream about the
only place that i admitted it was in my
diaries
and i found those where i wrote to
myself before i could even
consciously admit it that i did want to
be an
actor all the way back since 1988
but i never admitted it until i started
doing it and
it was turned in about 1993 that i was
like okay
i think i can do this i'm giving it a
shot and i love this
it's totally understandable that you
would fall into some form
of self-sabotage if it came that easy
if all of a sudden you're on dazed and
confused all of a sudden you do your
first two auditions you get the gig
everything's rolling you're young and
handsome whoo
come on dream night
i mean how did you self-correct
tell you what i did i uh i got
it really happened around 96 after i did
a film with time to kill
i remember the friday before time to
kill open that's the movie that
that i was the lead in a big budget john
grisham movie that was the one that made
me
famous all right so the friday before
that movie opened
i you know there's a hundred scripts i
wanted to do
i would have done anything to do any of
these scripts 99 no you can't
one yes you can i'm walking down the
third street promenade in santa monica
400 people in the promenade 396 minding
their own business
four of them checking me out two girls
that thought i was cute and a couple
other people maybe like my shoes
the monday following that weekend time
to kill opens that night
the monday following all of a sudden
out of those 100 scripts 99 yeses you
can do any of these matthew
one no all of a sudden that same
promenade walk i took
400 people now 396 were staring at me
and four people weren't one of them was
blind all right it was it inverted the
world became a mirror i noticed oh [ __ ]
i don't need any strangers anymore
people are coming up to me going like
i'm so sorry about miss hud and i'm
going
wait a minute number one what's your
name i've never met you how'd you know i
had a dog
whose name is miss hud and has cancer
you just skipped five
filters of howdy you know what i mean
and i remember feeling unbalanced about
it
i'm 23 at that time
i'm being told i love you i love you and
in my mind i'm going man we don't throw
that word around i've said that to four
people in my life
uh so i wanted to know what the heck was
real what really mattered and
i was looking for a place to go
i needed to get out i needed to go those
demarcations we talked about earlier i
needed to go break a long sweat i needed
to go out and let memory catch up see
what the hell was real what was not
so i packed up my stuff um
i went to a monastery for about a week
and then
i got back and i went off i had this
certain dream a rep
repeating dream that came to me and i
went to peru and floored the amazon
for 22 days and it was a forced solitude
nobody there knew my name they didn't
speak english
i was forced to be with myself and my
thoughts in my own company which i was
not enjoying
so after about 12 days of shaking the
monkeys off my back figuring out what
the hell i was going to forgive myself
for and
what i was going to lay down the hammer
and say enough's enough about
um i came out of it woke up one morning
light as a feather and
shook hands with myself and said we're
going to be all right man uh you're the
one person i can't get rid of
mcconaughey so we might as well get
along
and reentered and that recalibration
helped a lot
to disseminate through all the [ __ ]
and all the excess of affluence that was
coming at me at the time
and i found some discernment you know i
found some discrimination in my choices
again
um and moved on from there but i've had
to do that i've had to take off on my
own
many times to go recalibrate that sounds
like
a story of a man running and the rocks
fall right behind him
like you just missed it like also 23
years old you weren't a child star
but it was damn close like
we all know what happens when your
personality develops
in the spotlight and you're famous
almost no one gets out alive
i mean and i understand it i i i wasn't
ready
to go out to hollywood before i did
hollywood's not a place to go find
yourself
hollywood's a place where you can be
anything you want it's infinite yeses
well then the infinite yeses as you know
the all
the infinite options can make a tyrant
of any of us what is that noise that
keeps going off is that on your end
that's on my end what is it i think it's
emails coming in
it's a crazy ding thing
sign it is that what you get when you
get emails that would annoy
the [ __ ] out of me what's yours do
nothing
nothing i don't i check them once a day
oh see i don't text you know i don't i
like to email more than text
because i can press i can flag an email
i can't flag a text i wish text would
allow me to flag it oh i'm going to save
that to answer it later
and if i would just do text i may forget
you wrote and then
two weeks later ago i never wrote him
back right i do that
where's my delete it doesn't go ding
i don't know i maybe jody foster made it
out alive
she might be the only i mean you worked
with her did she
nor did she make it out alive of being a
child of fame
she made it out alive you know she was
yeah she was was she the coppertone girl
on the beach
she was a bunch of things she she wasn't
she in taxi driver
yeah i mean man she did you know who
else did ron howard
yes he did he's a very nice guy i ran
into him at a doctor's office he
couldn't have been nicer
and more normal and really enjoyed
talking to him
yeah solid um you know but i don't know
i've never talked to
them about how they navigated in their
youth
they obviously had some support because
you know you you i see the i see parents
with their with their children and they
want them to be in from the camera and
i've even seen some
set that we work with and the mothers
behind the camera like olin mills
photography going
cheese say cheese and the director you
go no no no no no
this is not olin mills we just want the
the child to be himself for herself
if they have the confidence to be
themselves in front of camera don't be
acting like anything this is not a
olin mills photo shoot um and so a lot
of times
i've seen the parents they're the ones
that actually
need the recalibration yeah um to go
whoa
don't be you're making your child
doesn't know who he or she is yet
and yet you're forcing them to try and
be someone else and that's their reality
there's danger in that yeah sure no
there really is it's it's very
unfortunate when you see that
um you've worked with kids that have had
to play
your kid like is that
does that feel conflicted to you when
that happens like you almost like
don't want them to do it no i i that's
been some of my most comfortable roles
as playing
a father or a father figure and i think
that's because
the one thing i always knew i wanted to
be in life as a father i knew that since
i was eight years old what i mean is for
the children themselves do you feel
weird for them
no no the kids that are playing your
child
like knowing that they're gonna be in a
film at a really young age and they're
gonna experience all this
um i mean i'll check in with you know
again what i've noticed is it's the
parent that may need the recalibration
the kid's just fine but then you see the
the the mother or the father
loving it more than they're loving it or
loving that child
is it from the camera we're going to be
famous yeah well
you know when i can i've tried to talk
about
are your values in line here because
you're your son or daughter's
future and who they are is depending on
how you deal with it i've also seen
parents handle it really really well
um you're going you're going to work you
have a job to do
if you have a talent to do that but you
still come home and you still do the
chores and you're still
my son or my daughter who acts just like
you do and we don't do any of that other
that bs you're not things aren't
thinking around here
and you don't want to steal i wouldn't
want i wouldn't want my child to be
raised
in hollywood by hollywood i now
you know early in my career i was like
no i would never want my kids if i have
them
doing what i do i've completely turned
to 180 on that um
i would love if my kids got into the
industry that i'm in it's been great to
me i've met some of the most creative
awesome people in my life but
there's a time i wouldn't want them to
go find out who they
are in a hollywood in the hollywood game
by being an actor or that kind of story
tell your own i want to know their own
story first before they're going to go
tell someone else's story
yeah i've likened it to like almost like
a chemical process like if you want to
make epoxy you have to add a bunch of
different ingredients and if you don't
add the ingredients while you're mixing
it up
it'll never be sure it'll never really
firm up it'll never be complete
and i feel like that's one of the things
that happens to a lot of child actors
like
the experience of people not knowing who
you
are you have to earn their respect you
have to earn their love
earn their friendship prove yourself not
have people love you before you even
meet them
that's just that seems toxic for
children
it just seems crazy i think it is highly
toxic yeah
you know we started off the conversation
on this topic 10 minutes ago not many
have recovered
no not many from that the insecurity the
lack of knowing who they are
the lack of talk about resistance you
know hollywood's a place of yes
yes of course you can be whatever you
want it's halloween every day
now wait a minute if you're playing
dress-up every day and you have the
option to be whoever the heck you want
and
you know you want to go to the club all
night uh
you can do that too everything's a yes
in those infinite yeses you can get
lost and not found um
yeah i think they you know you got to
have some structure and like i said i
went out at 22 23
i don't think i was ready to go out
there before i went out there because i
had a sense if i didn't
as much as i had a sense of who i was i
had a very clear sense of who i was
not um and that helped me because i was
able to see some things and be invited
to some things and be around some place
so i was like you know what
this is a stop not a stay for me
this isn't really going to feed me and
it really turned me on
this is a short term uh um you know
something i'm getting that's feeding me
in the short term but this isn't gonna
last is it
really who i am yeah i've i've talked to
a few
child stars that sort of got like miley
cyrus is one that i talked to recently
and
you know you see it in the conversation
when she's describing what it was like
to grow up famous
and it's it's a very difficult path and
i don't you know i think jody foster ron
howard there's a few that have gotten
through it
someone should actually sit down with
those folks and try to figure out what's
the common denominator
like how did they do it science there'd
be some great signs of how they did it
you know i a story about i had a
teaching tool
that had to do with something i i pulled
off in hollywood
from for my kids and i'm big on delayed
gratification
um and you know after i won the
the oscar for best actor my kids were
like what'd you get the trophy for
and i said well you remember a year and
a half ago
we were in new orleans pop i would go
away you'd wake up in the morning i was
already at work and i'd come home
and have dinner with y'all and tuck you
in and you wake up the next morning i
was gone again and remember you said i
look like a giraffe because i was so
skinny
yeah and i go well what i was doing for
those 30 days
when i was gone all day a year and a
half later
somebody said deemed that excellent work
and they gave me a trophy for that work
what i did a year and a half ago and
i remember i saw them click they were
like oh
oh our future is a compounding interest
you know what i mean we can ask
oh there you can build you can't do
something today and get rewarded
tomorrow um and it was it was an example
that worked
for them um of understanding
you know that you can that you can get
you can invest
and make choices to engineer more roi
you know i know that was a milestone for
you and obviously
you won the oscar for it but there's
something about these
physical transformation roles when when
an actor
does something where you realize like
they're they're
literally torturing themselves i mean
when you would
how would you get down to how much did
you weigh
i weighed 135 and look you know this
i was not torturing myself i was
militant the hardest part was making the
damn choice
it was my responsibility if i looked
like i do now
playing ron woodruff in dallas buyers
club you are out of the movie the first
frame oh [ __ ] he doesn't he's not
stage 4 hiv
i'm out what's my job i had to lose the
weight once i made my mind up
i did the smart thing i gave myself five
months i got on a diet
where i'd have my tapioca pudding or
whatever three eggs in the egg whites in
the morning
five ounces of fish cup of vegetables
for lunch five ounce fish cup of
vegetables for dinner
as much wine as i wanted to drink and i
lost 2.5 pounds a week like clockwork
no exercise as much wine as you wanted
to drink
much as a one how does it eat what kind
of diet is this
it worked 2.5 pounds and it didn't
matter if i was going to
the treadmill and burning 2 000 calories
a day or not
2.5 pounds a week clockwork and what
happened during that time this is
another reason that i really didn't
torture myself and people say oh my gosh
it's been so hard i was like no what i
learned from it
that the body is more resilient than we
give it credit for
i the power i lost from the neck down
equally or more so sublimated to the
neck up
i was so my mental game was so acute and
so on point
i was clinically smart it didn't matter
if i drank my wine until one in the
morning
at 4 30 a.m no alarm clock bang
i was up every morning had incredible
amount of mental energy
i had no leverage from my neck down i
mean
my knees i had no insulation anywhere
you know my body would hurt when i tried
to run
10 feet but from here up there's some
things i actually
miss about it what do you think what was
the process like why did your
brain work better when you were starving
yourself
i think because it wasn't relying on i
think on a cellular level
i felt my body going hey he's a baseball
term
you got people over there on the bench
in the dugout then you got people out in
the field that are you know
sitting in the uh in the bullpen not
working out
on a cellular level
cellularly my salesman that were in the
dugout and over there in the bullpen
had to get up and go whoa we're not
getting fed but we used to get fed we
gotta
we gotta exercise here we gotta come too
but hut
um because the my body's not getting
we're not getting what we used to get
um we're not placated by what we used to
get
our insulation's gone our our or what
we're relying on is go what we used to
rely on is gone so
i think my whole body woke up and my
brain got really
super super sharp on that as well so i
think it was the going without the there
was a bit of a
it was what i went without that
sharpened up and made my brain on the
cellular level much more hungry
what do you weigh normally 188
jesus christ so you lost 50 pounds
yeah there's roles where guys do this
where it defines their career in
something like robert de niro when he
gained weight for raging bull
uh christian bale when he did uh the
machinist yeah yeah the
there's these these roles where a guy or
a woman
just transform charlie's throne when she
played monster
they they transform their body and it's
it's like a
it's a different level of of commitment
and when you entered into that film that
was this the first time you'd ever had
to do that
yeah first time ever had to do it i mean
you you got jacked for that uh well i
don't know how jacked you were before
for that dragon movie
i'm sorry i forget the name yeah yeah
reign of fire bringing the fight i
[ __ ] love that movie yeah
that was a great baby god miss van zandt
it was a great movie talk about a guy
who was about no [ __ ] boy that was a
sobering character i i miss that guy
yeah it was a fun character but you were
jacked in that movie were you jacked
normally or did you have to get jacked
for that movie
i got more jacked for that look our
family my dad
we we come from um our anatomy and the
mcconaughey's have a big tricep
my dad you see you'll love this i'd be
sitting there as a kid
um and my dad was a big guy 6'4 265 you
know he
played kentucky under bear bryant got
drafted by the green bay packers he was
a big bear of a man
and he comes in the living room one
night and i'm in front of the tv
watching my favorite show incredible
hulk
and there's luke rick and i'm like
standing in front of the tv doing all
this he goes boy what you doing i was
like dad look at him man i mean he's got
these baseball sized biceps look at him
wow
and he goes uh-huh and he takes off his
shirt
and he goes let me tell you something
son he goes that right there
he pulled his bicep he goes that's nice
makes the girl scream
you know it's for show he goes
that right there he goes that's the work
muscle
that's the one that puts the roof over
our head that's for dough
show and dough the triceps were for
dough so i
had big triceps so when i went worked
out and if i take a little bit of
creatine my triceps go
bananas so that was a
minor transformation it wasn't that
difficult to do
no it was it was minor there's a lot a
lot of boxing
and uh um and and and just some
nice you know throwing some weight
around you just got fit
but for dallas buyers club yeah
i always try to stay within 10 pounds of
striking weight of whatever i need to do
for the roll
was it hard to make the decision to do
that for dallas buyers club though
because that was a
giant transformation i mean
it wasn't hard i was looking for
something to be all consumed with
something to be obsessed with a singular
obsession you know this is my job so my
life
revolved around that my wife made me
meals trust me i didn't go to pizza hut
and say no thank you to the pizza i'll
have a salad i did not even put myself
in front of temptations
i was a hermit i stayed in my
wife made me the meals and and i studied
and wrote and
created the character all day long and i
never got tired of that
so my world was i was in a bubble i just
put myself in a bubble for for
five and a half months and that
commitment to put myself on that
island to know that this is it's good to
have the singular obsession you
you cannot go far enough mcconaughey
that was there's a freedom in that
there's a freedom i've always found a
being having having a character that can
commit that much to
you cannot go far enough that that was
your thought process
yeah i knew when i got down to 135 i was
like oh okay
that's good and mind you we'll tell you
this when i started to eat more at 135
to say let's slow this train down and
quit losing weight
my body had already got the message and
had its blinders on that we're going
south and it kept going south
so that was a bit scary because i kept
losing the weight because my body had
gotten
already gotten in the in the rhythm of
losing weight and like i said it turned
a blind eye on getting any more food so
there was a tough transition there for
about two weeks to get my weight to
balance out again and say let's just
hold at 135.
so you drop below 135 at one point in
time
just went below with 135 got down about
and then brought it back up
now how long did it take for you to
physically recover from something like
that
were you back to normal man i'm still
recovering
really because i thought that i thought
that when i saw you in that film
i told my wife i remember saying this
like this is gonna take a long time for
him to bounce back
because i know how hard it is for guys
to cut weight for fights and i i know a
lot of guys that have really depleted
their body doing that and when i saw you
that gaunt and skinny i was like he's
eating his body
your body ate itself it's the only way
yeah i look i came back and i did true
detective after that and i got on true
detective i got to about 167 and held
and i loved that weight as well because
i had a little more leverage i had a
little more athletic ability a little
more insulation around my joints
but i was still pretty stripped and
ripped um
slowly coming back from that i did learn
this i had to come back very slowly
because i had heard stories about people
that go
well now i'm back now i'm going to gain
weight i can eat as much as i want and
that you can you can grow back and look
deformed you can your features can come
back
if you rush it they can come back in odd
ways so i very slowly
put the weight back on i then
did a roll a few years ago i guess it
was about
four three three years after dallas fire
stopped where i put on 47 pounds
so i was 220 what was that which it had
a lot more gold it's called gold it's a
hell of a lot more fun to put that
weight on than to take it off
where i was just cheeseburger king
and my family loved me in that role
because i was captain fun i was yes to
everything milkshakes for breakfast you
got it let's go
now that was i've never talked about at
that time
i was still mentally sharp not as sharp
as i was when i was down at 135
but at 2 20 libido was
through the roof i couldn't get i
couldn't catch a cold if i swam in the
damn canals of amsterdam man i was like
the abominable snowman
i was insulated um and had great energy
um during that time now coming back from
that i still got a couple things on my
back here around the way so i'm like
where'd that come that came up with that
rolling gold and what's that still doing
hanging around
you know so i did have to come back
slowly
um but i will say this
you know 188
since then that's my fighting weight
before
i look a little different than the 188
before then
before dallas buyers club it's a
different 188. so it did take a physical
toll
sure i would say you know even you know
neck and things like that you know neck
and and
you know bone structure is the same but
where and now but then how much of this
is just getting older too and having
less fat cells
right i'm not sure um but yeah it didn't
hurt
like i said i think i stretched my body
i i noticed when you know
when i got down to that weight at 135
if i you know tried to sprint 10 10
yards and i just my knees would buckle
i had no insulation and these hurt yeah
i watched it again recently just to kind
of get it into my head
and that's when i was thinking like this
is going to take a while to bounce back
from like i almost forgot
how gaunt you got it it was it was
striking
you know and that's a [ __ ] crazy
commitment man you drinking moonshine
what are you doing there
what is this some kombucha oh
it was not neither that or whiskey a few
hours
okay yeah your kombucha guy
i love that stuff daily i do too
yeah that'll that's great for the immune
system um when
you look at a role like a role like
dallas buyers club or something like
that
like what makes you choose a role does
it just have to resonate with you
is it who's involved who the directors
are the producers the the other actors
that are committed to it like what what
makes you
decide this is interstellar let's do it
all right well first what's the pedigree
of the people around me
the director the script uh the producers
are are they excellent are they right
for the story
um i do look at that but the main thing
i look at is like
this character um the last
12 years i've been able to choose
characters that's that made me shake in
my boots the right way
you know that good kind of scared where
you're like oh i don't know what the
hell i'm gonna do with this but i can't
wait to find out
um i like characters where the decisions
are really going to cost them where
there's consequences with every single
scene that they're in and the the
favorite consequences to have are
something like a ron woodruff it's life
or death consequences something like a
van zann
how can i remain from getting becoming
extinct
you know those are great okay we brought
it down to the bare necessities
um how to survive or how to stay alive
um
from that place then i can then i can
give my all now
choosing roles where i'm not going to
have any compression
from the ceiling to the basement of the
emotions i want to give
no one's going to tell me oh you can't
be that angry oh no one's going to tell
me you can't be that sad you can't cry
that hard no one's going to tell me you
can't laugh that hard
no one's going to tell me you can't hurt
that bad i don't like to be
i've been enjoying choosing roles that
have a really high ceiling and a
limitless ceiling in a limitless baits
basement
to where i matthew can can go as deep or
as high as i want to
with them there's a lot of roles that
i've done in my career for instance like
with romantic comedies where
those emotions are compressed for a
reason the ceiling you can't
laugh that loud you can't love that hard
you can't get that pissed off
you'll sink the ship of those movies
they die built for buoyancy
i've been enjoying the dramatic roles
and that's what i love about drama is
that
no it's to the individual actor your
ceiling of how much you want to love or
your basement or how much you want to
hate
go for it um there is no there is no
limit on either one of those
that's the kind of role that really has
been turning me on
and that makes me feel like i'm having
an experience in the making of the movie
in the architecture of the character
rather than just going and doing a job
and getting a paycheck
during the quarantine the lockdown my
family and i had movie night basically
every night
especially when the kids were uh doing
zoom classes
because you know it just it was we had
to do something different so
we mixed it up and we watched contact
again and i haven't seen contact in
forever
and uh first of all god damn what a good
movie that was
good that's a good movie and a
a great movie about aliens like like a
a movie that it gives you a
different perspective on the
possibilities of contact and
and just the fact that it was a carl
sagan book and there's just so much
good to it that character that you
played
was uh as a fascinating guy and i i kind
of feel like there's some of you
in that guy sure
i mean you are you you are
am i wrong here you are religious in
some way yeah
yeah absolutely and i want to i want to
bring this up in this day and age when
people go no i'm not religious i'm only
spiritual
you know what the latin root of religion
is
re lagare and lagare means to bind
together
re means again well in a world that's
saying i'm only spiritual because i want
unity that's exactly what religion means
we've bastardized the meaning of it over
time
and we've excluded people and we've
corporatized and such but yes i am
religious um
that character you know i had written
stories i'd written a
college paper called john wayne goes
west and it was about how do you
how do you how can you be a believer in
a world of science
and i remember writing things like
during the make of that movie like
science is the practical pursuit of god
um the two are not exclusive
they dance together there they they go
together
um belief in science and i never saw
those as contradictions
and that's part of what the reason i
attacked that role and became part of
that that movie i wanted to play a
person that had that point of view
of a believer in a world of science not
at the exclusion of science
and not at the exclusion of belief yeah
it's a confusing role for a lot of
people
if someone is a believer and also
a proponent of science because they want
to know
what are your literal beliefs like d are
you taking the bible at its literal word
or do you use it as some sort of a
guidebook
of the experiences of these people that
live thousands of years ago
that have been translated from multiple
different languages back to english
and is there wisdom in those
translations is there wisdom in those
original thoughts
these thousands of years of people
contemplating and and mulling on these
things and
that so many have used these as
a scaffolding for morals and ethics
and for societies yep
a it's it's it's i mean you know for
people that go
oh it's it's it's it's it's a it's a
circus book or people had no
non-believers and i'm like well it's
still the
the best one going um there's a lot of
great truths
that that come out of the bible and it
is open for
a lot of people it has been interpreted
and reinterpreted it has been translated
it's been handed down
um i for myself i don't know what to do
in my daily life with the burning push i
don't know what to do with that
um i do know what to do
with love your neighbor like yourself i
do know what to do with matthew 6
22 if they i be single that whole body
will be full of light
i do know what to do with some proverbs
that i can take into daily practice and
go oh i felt
my life i felt improvement i felt
success in my relationships and my
relationship with the day with my career
by following that um by treating others
how i wanted to be treated the golden
rule
so i i take the practical stuff myself i
mean try to try to utilize it and then
pick out what can work for me
when you say when you say you don't know
what to do with the burning bush like
what do you mean by that
i don't know what to do on a daily basis
with the teaching of
um and and then he you know and then he
he
he showed up as a as a burning bush or
the magic tricks and i don't know what
to do with
and jesus healed everyone that he and he
couldn't walk and now he touched him and
he can walk i don't know what to do with
that
i don't i don't know how to take that
into my life and go
oh there's something useful and
practical and healthy for you matthew
that you can practice there so the magic
um that leans in towards you know what
we would call now more fantasy i don't
know what to do with that i
there's there's philosophies there's
proverbs and there's teachings
that i think are very valid and very
helpful um that we could all be reminded
of that are in the bible that i do find
quite useful
yeah i think it's almost impossible to
figure out what they were trying to say
with a lot of the things that's why it's
so it's open to interpretation but also
open to manipulation and that's where
people have a real problem with it when
it's used for
to to separate people to exclude people
to marginalize people to judge people
but it's it's hard for people that
understand that
those aspects and that those things
happen to actually parse out
that there's good about it too and that
there's a lot of really valuable lessons
in these books 100 percent
um look i i get it i mean you
you know it's like a what are our what
are our fathers teach us
is your father still alive well i don't
really know him
i have a complicated uh family history
okay
well fathers are father figures i have a
stepfather
he's still alive and i'm close to him
well step father when he goes you'll
find out some things where the messenger
and the message
weren't exactly in simpatico sure you
know what i mean
does that mean that you throw the
messenger out because you're like oh
[ __ ] you weren't following all that
stuff
no you take the message this is the
stuff that you can that
that could work for you that maybe they
wanted it for you they couldn't follow
through
on it themselves there's certain parts
of the bible that have that too
you don't throw out the whole you can't
think it makes any sense to throw out
the whole book
it's what we're doing in society now i
mean we're we're
we're making people persona non grata uh
because of
something they they they do or you know
in in
and that is that is right now deemed
wrong or it's the hot point in a hot
topic right now
you can erase someone's entire existence
where the heck does some forgiveness go
and again that like
optimism it's not erasing the crisis
it's not saying there wasn't a problem
first it's not saying that there's
virgin parts of the bible that have been
people have bastardized
and used in the wrong way um but you
don't throw the whole book out
and say well it's all it's all bad then
it's all used because
it's false have you
encountered difficulty expressing this
uh in hollywood you know hollywood is
uh predominantly left-wing and
very secular or jewish in some circles
but
it's not like a place where christian
fundamental values
are espoused openly you know a lot a lot
of jewish folks are in hollywood and
that seems to be
okay with a lot of people but some other
religions
particularly if you're a fundamentalist
christian or if you have
christian values a lot of people frowned
upon that
why why why do you think that is and
have you had difficulties with that
i don't know i haven't had difficulties
i have had and i won't throw any people
under the bus
but i have had um
moments where i was on stage receiving
an award in front of
my peers in hollywood
and there were people in the crowd that
i have prayed with before dinners
many times and when i thank god i saw
some of those people go to clap but then
notice that
[Laughter]
bad thing on my resume and then sit back
on their hands oh
wow and i've seen
people read the room and go whoa that
wouldn't bode well for me in the future
if for getting a job or
you're getting votes or what have you um
i have seen that i've witnessed that
um i don't i don't judge him for it i
just wish you know that
that it seems like a silly argument
there's
it's a you know one of the things that
our
art are people some people in our
industry
not all of them but this there's some
that go
to the left so far as uh
our friend jordan peterson who's back um
saw his video being back
that go to the irreliberal left side so
far
that is so condescending and patronizing
to 50 of the world
that need the empathy that the liberals
have
gives and should give um
to to to to throw somebody's
illegitimize them because they say they
are a believer
it's just so arrogant uh and in some
ways hypocritical to me
um yeah so i haven't run into
you know i haven't headbutted trouble on
that but i've always you look my my
career i've pretty much gone my own
my own path and
by hooker by crook just trying to figure
a way out into what i was doing and
i haven't i haven't measured or noticed
where it has harmed or gotten my way of
what i wanted to achieve
in in hollywood i think he slipped
through the net
he got further far enough down the river
where it's not going to be a problem
well kind of like when i you know like
my mom when i first got
famous you know it's a great story in
the book um
right when i got famous i'm trying to
figure my own [ __ ] out right
and then uh next night i get a call my
buddy says hey you watching this i'm
like what you guys turn on hard copy
and there's my mom with a cameraman
taking a guy
through our house going this is where i
caught him in bed with melissa
[Laughter]
you know what i got him doing in there
oh don't worry about it it's no big deal
i've seen it a thousand times and i'm
going i call her up i'm like mom
what did you do she's like what i go
don't say what i can hear it
and you're on the other than the line
you're watching it too it's hard copy
she's like oh
i didn't think you'd find out
[Laughter]
eight years where my mom and i's
relationship was strained i couldn't i
didn't have a mother to talk to
to share things with cause hell would
show up on a hard copy the next night
once my career got solidified enough you
know
well i i slipped through the net i was i
was stable enough i went in and let go
of the rain and said mom you go for it
you can take the mic anytime you can hit
that red carpet wear your short leather
dress and talk whatever tell whatever
stories you want to
but again it took a while for me to feel
stable enough to slip through the net
and let her
go be herself as well this thing you're
talking about with uh
people disparaging people for their
opinions and their beliefs and their
the the way they're living their life i
think a lot of this is coming from
this condensed way of impersonal
communication that we're getting from
social media
i think it's this is so much of the way
people are judging people
and the way people are communicating
with people
one on one is how human beings are
supposed to talk
that's how we're supposed to work things
out and when you look at a person's eyes
and you experience their their feelings
and you read their social cues
that's how we communicate and that's how
we work things out and hash things out
and and figure each other out and maybe
someone has a different set of beliefs
than you but
they happen to be your neighbor and you
like them and you're like hey man
tell me what's it like to be a sikh what
what is it like to be a
muslim what is it what are your beliefs
as a a a quaker like what are you what
what's going on in your life tell me
i've i had a neighbor who was one of my
favorite neighbors i've ever had he was
a scientologist
and he was a weird dude man but he was
always friendly as hell
i would go outside we'd have weird
conversations about these things that he
was doing and
i just tried to figure him out and he'd
try to figure me out we you know we
always wave to each other we're always
friendly
i miss that guy but he uh he and i
if we were talking online i'd be like
you know if if i was
a younger man and i was dumber and he
said something about his belief
and i thought that was stupid i'd
probably say what kind of dumb [ __ ] is
that
you believe that nonsense written by a
science fiction author but
talking to the guy that that was never
the way i talked to him
when he and i were looking at each other
we're just two neighbors
trying to figure each other out and just
trying to be friendly and have a
harmonious neighborhood
well it's one of the one of the things i
i think you're going to like
uh about your new home the city
i think i mentioned this to you when i
when i when i called you to say welcome
you know one of the great things about
austin texas is even though it's
the the blueberry and tomato soup the
the the more liberal city in the
conservative state
you can see neighbors next door to each
other talking to each other and one has
a trump sign in the yard the other one
has a biden son in the yard
they're still having a conversation no
one's going sneaking out in the middle
of the night to go rip that other
person's sign out
yeah um it's when austin is at its best
it ha
it has that you know i think that the
you know and i've got young children
they're starting to get we don't allow
them on social media yet
but you see these people you're living
in a time where
you put out something of yourself
and your whole value of yourself is
reliant on
what the world out there strangers you
don't know comment about that
and if i put out a picture that i'm
really happy excited about on instagram
tonight
and if i'm going to look what the
reaction is and the majority says oh f
hugh mcconaughey this
all of a sudden i have a bad night i'm
having a bad time but if you go
the same picture and you go awesome and
this consensus awesome
all of a sudden you've controlled how i
feel and i'm having a great night i'm in
a great mood
so we're at the we're sort of at the
behest people of
we're reacting that's that's kind of
what we're doing more in this society
we're reacting and you look at
you know things that things that go on
on issues right now it it
everyone's reacting to to to things
instead of it's
instead of creating the story or having
an opinion coming out of the gate
um and hey i understand it to some
extent because
people getting you get hired and fired
on those things these days
yeah you know iron fired about you
you're hired and fired or not hired
because you don't have as many
people following your whatever it is um
that's a measure now of what we call
success
in this life you know or what's up at
the top in america
money and fame baby you got that
you've made it in america you are
successful we pat you on the back we
give you respect
i got nothing against money and fame i
got money and i'm famous
but that's not
where my value system lies or what i'm
what is the most important to me and
what i'm trying to teach my kids
there's a way to get that and if you can
do it in a way to have your value system
let's just play let's praise that
um but it's tough because that's not
what the world right now especially
america rewards
people for yeah i think
there's a real issue with social media
in particular with children
in that we're just not designed for that
we're not designed for that kind of
communication
and it's so easy to dismiss someone
who's just
text on a screen it's so easy to to
to shut people down and it's you see
people getting praised
because they're famous and because
they're wealthy i mean how much of what
social media is for a lot of young kids
is seeing famous people in front of
lamborghinis with a
million dollar watch on it's a bizarre
posing ritual that people are doing it's
very strange
funny story about that i'm in miami
southeast now mind you
i really like miami because it's so
obvious
i mean in l.a people get like
a boob job or a lip job or a calf shop
and they try to say no it's all natural
in miami they go i just got my calf job
i just got a boob job hold up hold up
calf jobs
how many people are getting calf jobs no
guys
will go get a calf implant is that real
that's still happening
and in miami they're proud they're
showing you like
they're out there's no shame in that
there's no embarrassment i'm not getting
that
all right i'm in miami making a film and
it was the beach bum
and i'm walking along the beach and
there's this guy
unbuttoned silk shirt got his gold
chains on he's all greased up and he's
leaning against his purple lamborghini
and he's got somebody taking pictures of
him and i'm just saying like what's
going on he's got the palm trees in the
back and the ocean so i asked him i said
what are you doing and he goes
oh man i'm getting this picture taken
from my tinder page man
just out there in the next 20 minutes
two other guys came by
and i ask i go is that your lamborghini
because no no i just rented it for the
day
for my tender page pick two guys walk by
in the next 20 minutes and paid him 50
bucks
to lean against his purple rented
lamborghini to get their tinder
page picked oh my god
i wonder if it works it's kind of work
it's got to work on someone
any and he got his you know got his rent
paid for for his purple lamborghini
yeah well miami you should have a
passport to go there it's uh
it's barely america it's a lot of fun
it's a great place
as a lovely city i love visiting there
but uh
i i don't think i could ever live there
i go to miami and i just go
you guys are [ __ ] out of control
it's the only place um before i was
doing my last netflix special
i was using these yonder bags and what a
yonder bag is
is you have to put your cell phone in
the bag when you go in there so you
can't film the show
or you can't talk on it and the idea is
that the people won't be distracted
because their cell phone will be in this
magnetic pouch you have it you have
possession of your phone nobody's taking
your phone but when you want to leave
or use the phone like someone someone's
going to call you maybe you've got a
babysitter you can go outside they'll
open the pouch up and then you can use
your phone
okay most shows i did this i did shows
all over the country the show's people
were more attentive they sat down
they didn't get distracted by their
phone and they just listened in miami
all they did was get up and go outside
so the whole show the [ __ ] show's
like an hour and 45 minutes
it's just people getting up and going
out and coming back and getting up and
coming back and getting up and coming
back
it was like people were constantly going
back and forth i don't know if they're
doing coke or if they're just
part but they were they the idea of how
not having their phone with them they're
like what what the [ __ ] i need my phone
they're so distracted so chaotic it was
a lot of fun though
i'm not even complaining where the
mannequins
even the mannequins have fake boobs it's
true
it's true it is true if you go to a
department store the man
the mannequins have giant fake boobs
yeah because look the girls that
want to buy those clothes also have fake
boobs they don't want some weird
natural body like how am i gonna know
what it's gonna look like on me
and again i'm not [ __ ] not miami i love
it here i love it yeah rather but i
always said if you want to starve to
death
open up a bookstore in miami
hey nobody buying books there nobody's
buying green lights they might get the
audiobook
and listen to it when they're on the
treadmill but it's it's a wild place
and and that show that i did the shows
that i did down there
they were fun i had a great time the
audiences were great they were
they laughed hard but they were just all
over the place
just up and down and back and up and
back and coming back and sitting down
excuse me pardon me
up more people i'm like you guys are out
of [ __ ] control
yeah yeah it's it's a it's an obvious
place
have you ever seen the documentaries
cocaine cowboys yes
well that's all the whole cult like how
it all got started down there
well the craziness let's those cooking
cowboys one and two of my all-time
favorite documentaries
just miami's got a wild [ __ ] history
yep it does and stories like that
make great films though because there's
some there's there's
real live stories about this country in
particular but this world in general
that you know like scarface or something
like that we're just like
this is kind of based on reality
you know it's one of the beautiful
things about a film
is that a film like scarface will make
you
look into that like well how much of
this is real did they really do that
oh yeah they really did send over
prisoners and release prisoners and send
them to america and they really did have
hundreds and thousands of murders and
gun violence all over the streets and
cocaine everywhere and that's real that
was real
yeah and it was happening well that
that's you know the best
it's always said you know truth changer
stranger than fiction but yeah i mean
i i one of the one of the words i have a
page in the book about my least favorite
word in the english language being
unbelievable um no it's all pretty dog
unbelievable
and and you see it happening like yup
wow i didn't think that was possible
well
damn sure was and it's usually stranger
than any hollywood script could make it
or more exciting yeah i say unbelievable
too often and it's sort of a placeholder
word for holy [ __ ]
right you know unbelievable but i it is
believable yeah for sure i mean you have
to be pretty odd
in this day and age to be unbelievable i
don't remember the last thing i saw that
was unbelievable
or whether it was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me um
i'm like you know boy there's one thing
you can depend on people being
its people yeah well so
in your life right now when you know
you've had this incredibly successful
career
and you i assume you're still writing
down these lists of things to do
when you when you look at like what you
would like to accomplish i mean you've
accomplished so much in the world of
acting and filmmaking
is there something out there that really
is
a a goal or a thought that's sticking in
your mind or something you haven't done
yet
yeah um
one of the things i got to do that's at
the top of the list is do my best to
shepherd three young children through
this life so they can go off and be
independent and autonomous and hopefully
competent young individuals that's
that's priority number one
but personally um there's a
there's a role that i've created and
assumed for myself called the minister
of culture
um and it's about finding a shared
competent value system and it's
something that
i'm gonna initialize it hopefully right
there in austin
um values as far as i can tell are the
the common denominator that they're
they've always been cool there's ones
that we can agree on they work
then they work now they will not go out
of style we're in such a time right now
where our social contracts are so broken
and they're broken with ourselves as
well we don't have expectations of each
other or of ourselves it's kind of
anarchic a nation divided
and in austin in particular as a very
popular and fast growing city
um it's changing a lot and uh
you know if austin is a city it
starts to consume more than it creates
um starts to not be conscious with the
with its money
starts not to invest in itself if too
many people come to austin
from california where they come from and
try to turn austin into why they left
where they were coming from
uh we're gonna look up in 10 years and
go what the hell happened man and
austin's got a lot of soul
got a lot of soul and i think it lies in
its values so this this
sort of campaign movement that i want to
push is reminding those of us from
austin why we love it there
austin's a place where nobody's too good
everybody's good enough um
and initiating and educating newcomers
and saying hey here's who we are who is
who we're not if you don't really want
to abide by who we are and what we
believe in
make it a stop not a state keep on
moving um
but i i think austinites have earned
that and i think
newcomers uh will appreciate that um
i want to look up in 10 years and be in
austin be a city that's an example of a
place that became a metropolis that held
on to its soul
um that you know the things you look at
around town crime rate
employment etc are still at numbers that
are incredibly respectable
um but we don't get don't get loose it's
a very creative town
you know and um like i said it's the
blueberry in the in the in the red state
but it's not an anarchic town it's not a
dirty town
it's not a sloppy town it's an
innovative town it's a creative town
and it's a young town um and you know i
think we all know
progress is not saying yes to every new
thing uh
progress is more about innovation but
it's also relying on tried and true
things that work have worked and will
continue to work
and i just want to remind us all the the
certain values that we have
in this is tonight and as individuals
and
you know where that goes from there if
that goes outside of austin and through
the united states is it's a scalable
idea that i dream of that could go
outside of the united states it could go
worldwide in success
um i like looking at cities and people
looking at cities as individuals that
have personalities
and uh reminding the people so let's
sell let's sell a city
to the people that live in it sell
austin to austinites and to people who
are coming to it
um that's that's that's my goal that's
what i'm into right now that's the
character that i'm inhabiting
right now in my life that's not on the
screen i'm one
i'm wanting to say hey the big show is
live life
the recorder is always on and
what's the story we're telling in life
that's that's that's the character i
want to play right now
in my life outside of my family uh
that's not on any kind of screen or any
kind of capsule that's gonna be on your
television screen it's just gonna if i
pull it off it's gonna be something that
i'm just living
and doing and coming there's something
about this town that's very unique
and i i knew it for years i've been
coming here doing stand up since the 90s
but you know when the the pandemic hit
and i decided to move here well i did
have that feeling like
boy a lot of californians are gonna move
here
how do we not [ __ ] it up and you and i
had this very conversation like don't
turn this into the place you left
so what specifically do you think
people need to not do to not do
yeah well you're coming to texas because
you got
no taxes you're coming to austin because
it's affluent it's happening you're
coming for the people the food the swing
it's happening it's a creative town it's
alive it's young
you got to pay a tithe ask
what austin can do for you ask what you
can do first
and personalize the place man i mean
give your tithe
to the city um it is a place like i said
that nobody's too good and everybody's
good enough we don't run over people to
get where we're going
austin will open up their proverbial
roller decks and you tell me if you've
if you felt this with yourself quicker
than any city i've ever been to
as a newcomer oh yeah you want to go on
some contacts here yeah
i mean in some ways i'm like austin boyd
you know you maybe could take more
ownership of that
ip but it gives it away it's very free
and we trust it's a very trusting town
and a town of second chances for people
but don't take advantage of that
freedom um understand that there's
responsibility to the freedoms that we
have
that there we do have to earn it uh
daily and don't just
over leverage ourselves and spend
because hey we're the most popular
person in
in school right now um don't get caught
looking in the mirror at ourselves
going oh aren't i great look at us we're
number one we're popular uh-uh
we uh we we still got boots on and we
still pull them on and strap them on and
get and get and get work done
even though we're young and innovative
in tech town we're still
a a classic and you know it's
accountability it's responsibility it's
fairness
to other to other people it's
understanding where
is austin idyllic and what is it really
because in some ways i think of austin
i'm finding out
it's not as ideal as i think it is in my
in my mind so i've got well i've got a
listening tour and i talk about the
diversity in austin
and it is a international destination
now talk about the
you know the the the equality of austin
you know the rule in austin has always
been all you got to do is be yourself
that's kind of the rule that's what's
cool about austin not what you think you
ought to be but just be yourself
it doesn't matter if you're blue-haired
short lesbian
american indian cowboy sheriff whatever
everyone's sitting at the same bar
having a drink and no one's yelling
about their place because if you
you're yelling about hey i want to let
you know how i'm different in austin
austin's like going
what were you yelling about we didn't
really care that's one of the great
things about austin at
best it celebrates differences when
austin is at its best austin's not
trying to homogenize people to say hey
we're all the same
no we're not we're all very different
and that's cool
but we do have some social contracts
amongst us we're a clean place we don't
like cheating steel to get where we're
going um
we look ahead but we appreciate
tradition at the same time
we take care as much as we can of of our
our natural
beauties around here at the same time
we're metropolis we're growing up
now how can we grow up and wide and
still grow deep
that's what i want to lean into is what
are the roots so we're not just
again looking up in 10 years and going
who do we become
where did all these socialites come from
you know
yeah um one thing that's plaguing los
angeles
that i'm starting to see here is uh
the homelessness intent form
all over the city los angeles is
out of control i mean it's bizarre that
it hasn't been handled
i mean i was just having a conversation
with my friend brian about it before the
show
and he was telling me that in burbank
they just shut that down they won't let
it happen
you can't just put up a tent somewhere i
mean
i'm an empathetic person and i think
that
you know all the people that are out
there that are homeless that are down on
their luck for whatever reason whether
it's
they've been abused or they're
alcoholics or drug addicts or whatever
it is
they're all our brothers and sisters and
i'm not a social engineer
i don't know what the solution is to
something like that but i know that it
gets out of hand
it's gotten out of if you go to venice
my friend bridget sent me a video
of her driving down venice and it's a
mile of tents i mean a straight mile she
got the phone out the window
and it's just tense everywhere
like it's it's crazy how does someone's
how do you put a stop to that without
being an [ __ ]
how do you how do you maintain empathy
and say hey you can't put a [ __ ] tent
up on the sidewalk
a great question and i don't know the
answer um you said it earlier look a lot
of these most of these people have a
mental challenge or they've gotten drugs
and so
you know in austin we're you know
putting something
up in some some vacated hotels um
i don't know to what extent that's
that's working um
you know i've got friends who have
businesses downtown
who who they've got homeless people
camping out in front
and if someone walks in they're they're
getting berated by this
person that's homeless that has this uh
uh mental
uh something mentally askew and they're
not in their nugget
i i don't i don't know um you can't
eliminate the problem but how do you re
you know this question of how do we
rehabilitate is an ongoing question not
just with homeless people
you know it's it's it's it's you know
with people that aren't
that that don't have uh mental problems
it's we have the question of of
rehabilitation i mean
and for those people i'm like well you
have to be sincerely seeking retribution
and and understand what you did wrong to
get the chance to be
forgiven and be and rehabilitate and get
a second chance
for the homeless people i think you know
i mean i think if you're going to go to
the
how do we how do we get them more
mentally stable or in and can we to what
extent
get them mental help um
and not just keep picking them up and
saying let's move them to this side of
the curb
and then well that curve got full let's
move them to this side of the curb
um and then you end up with a you know a
shanty town or something
um it's you know i think they're always
going to be to some extent
you know um there's going to be homeless
there's always going to be some
socioeconomic imbalance
i don't think we're ever going to that's
another thing that i think we have to
as a people especially on the left have
to realize
this whole perfect equality amongst all
of us and perfect justice i don't think
that's
a possible destination for anybody
i think it's great to keep america is
there's a constant chase to chasing a
jet
yes it's it's we never will get there
and that's the point just keep chasing
it try to have a little
ascension in our in our journey going
forward and a little bit of evolution
but we're never gonna arrive at this
utopian state where
ta-da we did it it's it's it's it's the
garden of eden before
an apple was eaten you know it's not
going to happen i don't believe
um so i don't know i question how
how the best way to rehabilitate
situations and like the homeless one uh
um
all the time and i don't i don't know
the answer i do if we can get them some
mental help
and then give somebody you know not just
if we can make jails not just a holding
cell
i mean think about it if jails really
worked once you've done your time
you ought to be even money right yeah
yeah you should be better
you're not even money you're coming out
with the scarlet scarlet letter on you
and you're gonna have to work five times
harder than the next guy to get that job
um you know if you're an offender of
such you're going to be found and
located and they're going to share your
location through
through the city and you're going to
find out um from your neighbor that
you're moving in
and you can understand the people going
i don't want that somebody's living next
door to me
right well if rehabilitation worked it
would be like well no it's okay because
they did their stint
it doesn't really work like that so it's
a constant uh
uh question i have about about how
what's the best way to rehabilitate
yeah no one seems to have an answer i
mean it's uh everyone throws their hands
up in the air
and just keeps on moving just what do
you
i don't know you know one of the things
you were talking about before
jordan peterson talks about that
equality of
outcome is a terrible idea equality of
opportunity
is a fantastic idea the opportunity to
succeed
but the problem with equality of outcome
is there's not equality of effort
and it's one of the beautiful things
about society
is that you and this is what we're
talking about before about
reading your memoir and reading an
autobiography of a successful person is
realizing
that there's work to be done there's
things you have to do in order to
to be this person that that people to
admire and it doesn't come easy
and some people aren't going to do that
work and if they're not going to do that
work they're not going to achieve that
outcome
and that's just life and you know and
the equality of opportunity
you know that's not even real because
different people start off at different
blocks in life they start off in
different spots
they start off with different challenges
and and different
physical attributes and and and physical
problems everyone has their own hand of
cards that you're dealt
yeah but treating people equally and
giving people the best possible chance
that we can as a community and as a
culture
that's what we all strive for and the
problem with
the homeless situation and the problem
with prisons it's a similar problem is
that the downtrodden the people that
have hit a bad spot in the game of life
like what is our responsibility to them
and if we are a community like there's
only three of us and one of us is [ __ ]
up
we go hey let's help mike you know he's
he's [ __ ] up let's let's tr
try to bring mike into the fold and and
give him
some life lessons and and give him some
love and hope that we can
bring him back up to a point where a
couple years from now we're looking back
on this going hey
look you used to be over there and now
you're here and everything's great
that's what we'd ultimately love but
there's almost
too many challenges and too many people
and and everybody has their own problems
so people throw their arms up their arms
up in the air and they keep moving and
these things don't seem to get better
the prison population seems to increase
homeless population especially during
this pandemic has increased
i don't have answers you know i really
don't so it's i'm spinning my wheels as
much as the next guy
yeah yeah it's uh
you know it's a question that's yet to
be answered on many levels
um before this time after the after this
time
you know that equal opportunity that's
that would be the gig that would be
there because then then you could
measure
because we are all born with different
innate abilities
and if we're fortunate enough to be in a
position we go well
i'm going to do what i'm good at and i'm
going to work my backside off for it
um and i'm going to get educated about
i'm willing to put in the work
america is a place that that's the
american dream you could that's what
they mean by the land of opportunity if
you
you should have the chance to pursue
what you want to do and if you're
willing to work for it and get educated
on it
you have an opportunity to make a life
i understand there's not complete equal
opportunity across the board i
understand that i
personally was born uh with different
innate abilities
than you or someone else i was also born
with more opportunity more opportunities
than a lot of people
i was born into a two-parent family um
that's one of our biggest diseases i
think
that we have in the states is that the
the the the family unit breaks up
sometimes too quickly uh too easily you
know mom or dad
jets uh if the going gets tough too
quickly um
so you know i i you know i was some
would say symmetrically speaking i'm a
good-looking guy so that's got me in
doors
that maybe it wouldn't have got other
people into tried to do my best once i
got in the door i'm not going to
apologize for any opportunities i've had
but i do understand that i've had
opportunities
that other people have not had i've
created many on my own
but i've also been introduced and met
people who opened those doors for me
that would not have been open for other
people um
yeah what do we what do we do with them
i think there's a place
and this is what i'm striving to get to
and understand more and more
none of us do a damn thing about
anything unless it's personal
intellectually we talk about it
it makes sense but we really don't take
action until it's trespassing on our
walls and it's gonna affect
me or you or my family that's when we
go okay i'm gonna take action so i think
whatever we do has got to be personal
um the the the the choice that i'm
making for my own
selfish choice for me there's a place
where
there's a choice where that also is
what's best for the most amount of
people
where the personal choice is also the
best choice for the most amount of
people
i call it the egotistical utilitarian
that's where the eye meets the we
um that's that's where where what we
want is what we need
and what we need is actually what we
want or what's best for us
is best for the most amount of people
where what where were the most
we're actually the most selfish or we're
the most selfish we're actually the most
selfless
that's the place where when i talk about
like green lights
there's a place to create green lights
that are best for ourselves
and others at the same time that's the
honey hole i don't know exactly
what that place is all the time but
that's the place i think we could all be
a little more conscious
of of how we go about moving forward and
making choices based on that
austin seems to be of a manageable size
as i was trying to describe this to one
of my friends in l.a he's like what's so
great about austin i was like first of
all
people aren't devalued because there's
not too many of them
there's a problem with when there's too
many people
then people become a nuisance there's
too many of them
austin doesn't have that problem so when
i look at like the homelessness problem
in austin like you know what this is not
out of control yet
this seems like you could still fix that
like someone's
got to realize that this could get out
of hand
and this is a thing that you can kind of
you it's it's
within the boundaries of resources
to step in and manage this and
now yes before it gets out yeah we look
up in 10 years ago [ __ ] it's too late
it's out of control
like that yes yeah to just grow and
and turn our backs on that not look at
it and now all of a sudden it's out of
hand and i don't know what to do with it
it happens quick
it happens quick venice two years ago
was not this there was a few tents
every you know here and there you'd see
tents now it's
[ __ ] bonkers and i would i i mean
obviously you're dealing with a much
larger population
in california but this this place is
special
i mean it really is there's there's it's
it's it's a
great size and the people here are
really exceptional it's it does have a
personality
it has a very unique like a mixture of
cowboys and hippies it's a weird spot
you know and it's that melting blending
of all these different types of people
here
has made it very tolerant and very
unique and the fact that there's
university here and there's a lot of
artistic people and musical people and
creative people
it's a real it's a real good spot and
i'm happy to be here but i don't want to
[ __ ] it up
i hear you well there's a lot of you
know there's there is a community
in austin and austin at its best does
come together
and realize that it has an identity to
move forward with to protect
um and you're right it's not so big and
i believe that it can grow
and but it can grow while still having a
sense of itself and its own identity in
it to protect that identity and grow
forward
turn the page progress yes it's coming
but also preserve the core
dna of who we are we're no longer the
little hippie town that
just had some music in the capital and a
university
no we're dot com tech town we're banker
town lawyer town international
destination
all those things that's fine but in that
there's a
there's a you know austin has i want to
help define
by listening to a lot of austinites as
well what our constitution is in austin
that's separate
from anywhere else so this is something
you're you're actively
trying to do you said a minister of
culture is this something you you have a
thought in your head of how to
how to do this yes i have
a shared values campaign that i've put
together
um and i want to
sort of advertise and sell austin to
austin all around austin
and it's just sort of sort of uh
value-based aspirational messages just
to remind us
who we are to to keep the community as
tight as possible
to form expectations and solidify
expectations amongst ourselves
um so if someone acts outside of those
they're noticed
and they're kind of nudged back it's
another thing austin does very well
austin austin i don't know how it is now
um
since we've had like uh the the protests
with black lives matter and stuff
but austin used to be um
there was a great relationship
with the police force not just with me
with seeing matthew mcconaughey walk
down the street
with john and jane doe you
gonna crawl you know you went jay
walking across sixth street they caught
you before and like nudged you over and
said hey don't do it before they gave
you the ticket there was a
there was a play of like they were part
of the community they could they felt
like you know
you give them a wave you didn't see a
cop in austin go oh [ __ ]
you you saw when you waved and if you
they weren't looking
uh you never felt like they were looking
to get you um
crime was low you know so we'll see how
that relationship has to be worked on in
the city of austin
um right now you know quite a bit
yeah what were your thoughts when the
the whole
idea to defund the police came to
fruition
well let's break that down one defund
the police that moniker
if you if you wanted to to say
it's almost like it should have been
renamed because defunding police does
not sound anything like there's been
money reallocated to different
areas of handling some police exercise
it sounds like
you got a million we're taking 300 000
good luck yeah
um and that's not exactly what it is to
be fair um
i
the community and the police and not
just in austin but all over
and i think they are doing this in miami
to bring up miami
need to get back together and the
community needs to say here's what's
unfair
here's how here's how i feel unfair as a
black man or a person of color or or
whatever whatever situation
here's here's here's my problem
with my relationship with you as cops
well the police got to get clear to go
okay our whole force isn't screwed up we
have to have law and order do we all
agree on that
yes we can all agree on that we got a
few bad apples that either need to be
trained better
um so we don't have those kind of bad
apples or people or cops
choking under under under on not and i
mean the word
as in fumbling at the goal line i don't
mean literally joking i mean that
that don't follow through on on on their
duty in the right way
when they're under that when they're
under the gun under the heat of the
moment that's what i mean
there are cops that have done that so a
few of these bad apples
need to be removed but they also we need
to make sure we're training them
better now also the cops need to go to
the community and go can y'all remember
and understand our point of view that
we're like the tow truck driver
we're not called when there's good news
we're called when it's bad news so we're
coming in
going looking for trouble all right so
we're already under stress if we even
get a call so can y'all help
us in our way that we communicate can
we get trust again that if a cop says
hey
stand still take your hands out of
pocket hold him up yep i'm doing that
that we're not going to be something's
not going to happen
to us uh um that shouldn't that there
will be a
a you know cause obviously the
situation's like that you're not being
called you're not in that situation when
it's good news
you know so everyone's already tensions
are high but
that's uh you know as far as the fun
we're gonna see
my we're gonna see if this reallocation
of money like in austin and other places
how that works i mean my first gut
instinct was
i don't see how that repairs the
relationship
between the community and the police
force i don't see how that's that's
coming together
it it it's i don't see how that's gonna
rehabilitate that relationship
um and now you have spite on on on both
sides
um again we're going to see i don't know
if we really had a bird in hand when we
made the change
do we have we practiced these other have
we seen these other forms where the
reallocated money goes to for 911 calls
and stuff we've seen these other forms
work have we seen them be improvements
i don't know um so hopefully
we'll see if this is just sort of guinea
pig in the idea we'll see how it works
but
um i i'm i'm more for saying okay
instead of taking away your money and
your funds which you could use to
train better and uh work on the
relationship of what your what your job
is and what you expect
and what communities expect from you i'd
rather have done that than
pull money from them so we're going to
see how this experiment goes
yeah i couldn't agree more i think they
need training they need more training
and more understanding and i think we
all need to understand that there's
a tremendous amount of these people that
are under insane stress
every day and they probably have massive
ptsd
and you know if you're every time you're
pulling somebody over you're worried
about getting shot
every time you're visiting someone's
apartment for a domestic abuse case
you're worried you're going to get
killed you're going to see someone
killed you've seen murders and deaths
and
the human mind is not designed to deal
with that kind of stress
day in and day out and a lot of these
people are
you know when you see these horrible
reactions
that cops have to situations where they
do completely overstep
their boundaries and and abused people
yeah i think a lot of those people are
really [ __ ] up by the time they get to
that point
and i don't yeah a lot of people were
[ __ ] up before
that's right or they got where before
they even became a cop or they became a
cop for the right reason
uh they had pro personal problems
and we need to filter those people out
and that also comes through training the
same kind of training that they filter
people out through the military
you know when you want to be a navy seal
you got to go through buds
and good luck if you have a lot of
character flaws
you're not going to make it you they
will be exposed and i think that
counseling and and training and then
communication with the community is what
we need we don't need to defund them it
seems like a popular social sentiment
that people are are repeating because it
puts you
in this ideology of a person who cares
and is progressive
but i don't think it's ever been fleshed
out i don't think people have thought it
out in the long term
and if you're looking at the
consequences of how this is playing out
in new york city
homicides are up by hundreds of percent
burglaries armed robberies everything's
up
it's not good the the defunding of the
police has been
horrible for new york city the the
consequences have been the exact
opposite would everybody hoped they'd be
right and i'm worried about that here as
well but governor abbott has stepped in
and said he's going to put a stop to
that which is uh you know there's
talk about not giving the the the towns
that do this
they're not going to have access to
property taxes and this is
you know obviously there's no income tax
in austin in in in
in the state of texas so the governor
supposedly stepped in
and going to iron this out so i'm hoping
it
works out and cooler heads will prevail
me too i'm with you
training and have more reverence for the
job and understand
they're called in when they're not
called in when it's good news you know
my my brother
rooster has a real good interesting take
i think
on like you know gun control um and
texas is a big
uh right to carry state and a gun a gun
state um
but he brought up the samurai sword how
there was a reverence
for it and i remember how we were
brought up you you you got your toy gun
and then you got your daisy
one pump and until you had mastered that
like not turning and ever
if you turned and even though it wasn't
cocked if it was aimed at someone nope
you got the gun taken away from you
you know what i mean but you had to
master the daisy gun first
and then after years of that you moved
up to the 22
and you had to master that and you had
to make sure it was always unloaded and
put back in the case you've got a
reverence for this tool there's a
long sort of initiation reverence before
you could move up
to a larger gun yeah we've lost a
reverence
for that tool and the samurai sword is a
good example
because there's a reverence for that you
there's an initiation period to get to
where you could have that
right and and i think that'd be you know
that's kind of one of the places where i
lie with the uh that it's too
easy uh to get to get a gun
sometimes that there that there should
be that background check which goes back
into when we're talking about with
police force background check training
have a reverence for the job
understand the expectations understand
it's a high-stress job
can you handle it let's learn how to
handle it
because they have to call audibles in
the moment that our life
audibles yeah and as we said get rid of
the ones who can't
because it is a hard job and hard jobs
are not for everybody
and i think that and that's that
punishes
the good cops when someone does a
horrible thing like the george floyd
case
all those good cops who would never
think about doing that
ever in their life ever are lumped into
the same category as that guy and i
think that's awful
yep i agree yeah um
listen man i enjoy talking to you this
is great i really do and i
wish you luck with your book and i've
loved your movies and uh i wish you
nothing but success and
and uh let's get together and break
bread someday i look forward to it
joe thanks man enjoy talking to you and
i look forward to doing in person let's
do it brother
thank you thank you good luck with the
book goodbye
[Music]
you